[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
today
[Music]
convenient health budget support
the therapy notes would be signed
support for job creation in the
investment planets
and the pork that we have to be saying
that it doesn't internationally to take
the program free of him
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
extinction
[Applause]
from Her Excellency dr. Ursula Van der
leer Thank You Prime Minister that could
not have been a better country to choose
when you still care for my very first
visit I think that if your Pia has given
hope to a whole continent and you have
shown to the continent and to the world
that any conflict can be brought to an
end
we've talked about manemma the principle
behind it peace indeed needs
determination please needs vision needs
courage it was very courageous what you
did that you were successful and it's
precisely with what you reached this
peace deal for Ethiopia with Eritrea
after so many years I want to
congratulate you prime minister and all
the people of Ethiopia for the noble
[Music]
and grateful that time today
improvement is abuse
one thing but it is not
in the country and
but the testing for the youngest prime
minister and only
woman as c-plus of gender bones
in interest and of course the children
is we've been talking about
but very ambitious goals
and
well at the outset now like that combat
vet dr. O'Sullivan on assuming the
leadership of the president I also would
like congratulate miss hotline
as per your appointment as EU
commissioner for an international
partnership and I believe they will
benefit from the new leadership are they
are well experienced that was in pistol
secreted and it's a very good team ever
combination which will make significant
impacts in new member states as well no
relationship between even Africa we took
the new change in EU with great passion
and interest and you also demonstrated
that viability gas
the first official visit
think about that in welcoming to
Ethiopia I would also like to express my
appreciation for selecting Ethiopia
slate in Africa and also planning to
work with Africa with ethiop as well I
think that's the right decision for
Europe is the right priority to work
with Africa we also appreciate in our
satisfied with the excellent relations
between Ethiopia and you he was
supporting us for the last four decades
also recently creasing the financial
support if
we'll still demanding more financial
support because we are ambitious as
Madame president mentioned when you are
young Prime Minister you're also more
ambitious and you wanna deliver more so
as the Livermore for our people we need
financial support for from Europe and
that helps us realize our vision
especially our home the only committee
form agenda which mainly focuses on
Muhammad imbalances also unemployment
challenge will face in today when reduce
unemployment and when I'm also with
microphone on any star institutions on
providing visa from service for
investors and that will have a
significant impact more economical in
the bourse
so in general we'll very much grateful
for your support for your visit and we
hope our relationship will be fruit in
the next few years under your leadership
thank you for coming thank you very much
dirty tricks
I will ask everybody to remain secret
White has I came to the Prime Minister
and the president in decades